hey everyone this is shootie from simply
learn today i will be talking about a
very interesting topic that is asset
security this video will give you a
complete insight into CSS piece asset
security domain so without further delay
let's get started through this video you
will understand what is cissp the need
for asset security
what does asset security and finally you
will look into the various domains under
set security before I directly start off
with asset security let's quickly brush
up our knowledge on CISSP as you might
be aware CSS P stands for certified
information systems security
professional this certification is one
of the toughest certifications in the
domain of cybersecurity CSP trains a
candidate to become an information
assurance professional CSP is considered
the gold standard information security
certification CSP has a total of eight
domains let's have a look at the eight
domains first we have security and risk
management and then we have a set
security security engineering
communications and network security
Identity and Access Management then we
have security assessment and testing
followed by security operations and
finally software development and
security as I mentioned earlier in this
video we will focus on the second domain
of cissp which is asset security so
let's understand the need for asset
security through a small scenario well
it was yet another regular D in Tim's
organization everything was going on
fine until the organization faced a
cyber attack the hacker hacked all the
servers in Tim's organization the
organization had loads of data not all
of the data had the same level of
protection the level of protection
varied from one piece of information to
another in this scenario the hacker
could hack into only that particular
data which was less protected however
this cyber attack had a huge impact on
the organization in addition to this it
was also discovered that there was some
flaw in the information classification
process that exposed even since
- a cyberattack in other words even
crucial data was left with very less
protection this gave rise to asset
security asset security is defined as
the process of collecting and protecting
assets such as data and devices asset
Security helps an organization
understand and classify data with
respect to its importance which in turn
makes sure that highly valuable data
receives the most protection asset
security achieves its goals through its
domains the domains are information
classification then we have data
classification data lifecycle data
remanence and finally we have data loss
prevention each of these domains have
different goals all of these domains
together make up a set security now
let's have a look at each of these
domains individually first up we have
information classification as you saw
what happened in Tim's organization it
is understood that importance of data
where is largely we have to classify
data before we can move on to protecting
it we need to be able to identify which
is the most crucial data with respect to
organizations information classification
is defined as a process of segregating
data based on its importance to provide
adequate level of protection to every
piece of data information classification
is different for each sector based on
their objectives the classification
varies in the general sector information
classification is used to minimize risks
on crucial information whereas in the
government or military sector it is used
to prevent unauthorized access and
finally in the commercial sector it is
used to keep sensitive information
private here it is seen to it that
information is not disclosed to a
company's competitors let's now move on
to our second domain that is data
classification as the name suggests here
data is basically classified based on a
set of considerations here we will look
into factors like data retention
requirements then data security
requirements data disposal methods data
encryption requirements and finally
compliance requirements so these are the
factors which are taken into
consideration
while classifying data this entire
process of data classification is taken
care of by the data owner in addition to
the classification they also analyze the
use and value of the available data to
the company finally the data owner also
annually reviews the data classification
before classifying data an important
step is to understand the data lifecycle
all of us speak of data all the time
however do we know the various steps a
piece of data goes through well for that
let us have a look at the third domain
data lifecycle we will start off from
the data creation step and understand
what happens to the data after that as
you see on your screens we have six
steps in the data lifecycle stage they
are create store use share archive and
destroy starting off with the create
phase this is the first step in data
lifecycle here
new data is generated or the existing
data is updated after the data is
created we use data repositories to
store the created data without storing
data we cannot derive any information
from it hence this step is very crucial
in that third phase data is viewed or
used in some application are processed
in addition to data being viewed and
processed it is also shared between
various users and customers our fifth
phases archive here data which is not
used frequently that is inactive data is
identified and then moved into long term
storage systems and finally we have the
destroy phase as the name suggests data
is simply destroyed here data can be
destroyed either digitally or physically
not to forget you cannot simply destroy
data it should be done based on
regulations but have you wondered what
happens if data is not destroyed even
after we try our best to erase it well
this gives rise to data remanence in
simple words data remanence is a term
used for the residual of digital data
which remains even after attempting to
erase that particular data data
remanence should be avoided as it is not
good to have remains of a piece of des
which was intended to be destroyed
security professionals should be well
versed with techniques to avoid data
remanence so how do we tackle data
remanence for this we have various
methods they are purging clearing
overwriting d causing storing and
finally destruction let's have a look at
each of these methods individually and
understand how they help in tackling
data remanence first up we have purging
purging is done to minimize risks on
crucial information in clearing data
from storage devices are removed however
it can be reconstructed by using various
software third we have overwriting here
we write over the original data several
times so that the original data cannot
be recovered d causing is the method
used to destroy data on magnetic storage
tapes next up we have storing before
storing data on media the data is
encrypted for the purpose of safety
finally the sixth method is destruction
here storage device which hold the data
are physically damaged incineration
crushing and shredding a few of the
methods used for destruction now let's
move on to a fifth domain data loss
prevention in this domain various
security measures are adopted that will
help in making data available to only
the authorized users here we will look
into four of such measures the first
measure is data inventory in this step
data is identified and then classified
in the second step the data flow is
plotted over the lifecycle the third
measure is data protection strategy here
a number of risk assessments are
performed the fourth measure is
implementation in this step we take up
cases which have had a history of data
loss for testing purpose those were the
five domains under asset security in
addition to these it is also required
that we understand the term privacy with
respect to asset security privacy is a
very crucial aspect when it comes to
WestEd security information privacy and
data privacy are more or less the same
this term is used to differentiate one
person from another
it relates to the personal data stores
on computers so what kind of data falls
under this category well we have data
such as medical records office data
financial data etc which fall under this
category to Apple privacy we use
technologies like pseudonymous Asian
tokenization and anonymization well
pseudonym ization refers to a data
management process an anima zation
refers to a process of either encrypting
or removing personally identifiable data
so that people who the data describes
remain anonymous and finally into
organization a sensitive piece of data
is substituted with a non sensitive
equivalent so before I wrap up let us
have a quick look at the topics we have
covered in this video on asset security
we started off with brushing up on water
cissp then moved on to understand the
need for asset security through a small
scenario then we looked into the various
domains of asset security the first
domain being information classification
here we understood what information
classification is for each sector we
then moved on to understanding data
classification and what a data owner
does we also looked into the data
lifecycle phase which consists of create
store use share archive and destroy then
we moved on to the data remanence domain
where we learned the various methods
should tackle data remanence finally we
looked into the data loss prevention
domain and understood the different
measures which are taken to keep data
safe from unauthorized access in
addition to this we also learnt about
privacy so this brings us to the end of
this video I hope you guys found this
informative and helpful thank you for
watching keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here